She lives in Tokyo.
He lives in Kyoto.
She's a cab driver.
He's a crab diver.
Lately, she's been thinking she might be forever alone,...
...and he feels as dull as a veneer floor.
She longs to hear her ex's warm voice,...
...whilst he stares at the microwave, remembering his ex's lasagna.
She visits Dr. Koyshiro,...
...he visits Dr. O'Yorkish, but nothing works.
Until one day, her friend Dolly Dylan invites her to a costume party.
Dolly is a friend of Lynda Lloyd, who in turn invites him.
She dresses as an apple pie.
He puts on a pineapple costume.
And as she steps into that nasty old train,...
...he drives miles down a tiny slant road.
At the party, she walks away from a guy trying to negotiate moths.
And bored as hell, he decides to get something to eat.
And then they finally meet.
Her name is Agostina, and his is Santiago.